[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILIP: Hello, everyone.
This is "The Flutter
Boring Show" again.
This is me, Filip, and Emily.
EMILY: Hello.
Welcome.
FILIP: Yeah.
Welcome to "The Boring Show."
Emily is new in
the Flutter team,
but she's been writing
that code for a while.
She's coming from-- she's
a compiler engineer, right?
EMILY: Yep.
FILIP: So today, we are
going to finish what we
started the previous episode.
And we are going
to add animations
because that's one thing
that people are asking us.
EMILY: And you always
need a compiler engineer
to show your animations.
FILIP: Exactly.
That's why we need it.
But first, obligatory--
"Flutter Boring Show"
is about one hour long.
It's about doing stuff,
and then having problems,
and then fixing them,
and always recorded.
Nothing is edited
out, basically.
And this is because
we think that it's
more interesting and more
educational to see us fail
and to see all these things
that you wouldn't normally
see in an edited video.
EMILY: Long form live coding.
FILIP: Yes.
Yes.
We really like the feedback that
you are giving us on YouTube.
There's a bunch of questions.
We're trying to answer them
on YouTube in the comments.
But some of them we want
to highlight here as well.
So let me just quickly see.
So there's many questions
about Google Maps,
which are not supported as
a widget in Flutter yet.
It's coming, so we don't
really have much to comment on.
What we know is there is a--
EMILY: Yeah.
There's open source
leaflet maps where you
can embed maps into your app.
That is currently working.
There's some demos online.
And then the Google Maps
people are hard at work here.
So hopefully very soon.
FILIP: Yes.
And just to be
clear, if you want
to show a map as a different
activity, that's possible.
But yeah, we get it.
You probably want your
maps to embed in things.
And that's what
we don't have yet.
Another question by
Mohamed [INAUDIBLE]
was about Unmodifiable
List View,
which is something that
I'm using heavily in block.
And in many other
places where I'm like--
we have a stream of lists
of articles, for example.
We don't want the
consumer, the view,
to be able-- even though
we trust ourselves,
we don't want people to be able
to modify the list that we are
publishing through the stream.
So that's what Unmodifiable
List View is for.
It's basically-- it's what
it says on the [INAUDIBLE]..
It's unmodifiable.
So you can be pretty
sure that people will not
mess with your data for like--
if they're listening
to your stream.
That's the only reason.
If you are, for
example, prototyping,
you don't need to
worry about it, really.
EMILY: Just a regular
list view is totally fine.
FILIP: Yes.
And the last-- oh, and last
but not least, there's the--
[INAUDIBLE] asked about--
OK, block is neat,
but there are things
happening inside the block
that I might want to know--
for example, showing
a progress indicator
while I'm loading something.
EMILY: Yeah.
Because the problem with
block is you basically--
it's abstracting away all
that information about--
it's trying to get the
information, and now it has it.
It's just like, here
it is to the view.
So--
FILIP: Yeah.
So that's what we're going
to do today, I think.
So because we were going to
talk about animations anyway,
and because that's a really
good thing to have when
you're loading stuff--
to have animation--
we're going to try, in the
next hour, to do just that.
The last thing--
I want to show something
that people are not maybe--
people assume because
of how Flutter
works that it goes directly
to OpenGL, that accessibility
is not really supported.
It is.
So I just want to show here.
If I turn on the
accessibility mode--
and I'm not super familiar
with how that works.
But if I go--
yeah.
There is one of
these things where--
yeah.
So I'm going to open the
[INAUDIBLE] app here.
It's a photo app.
But as you can see,
it works as if it's--
everything is there.
So it actually reads out things.
I can go here.
Buttons work, and are
accessible, and all that.
So--
EMILY: And if you've
been watching the
show, you saw that
we did nothing--
well, I-- Filip and Matt and
Andrew have done nothing,
basically.
It all built in out of the
box, which was pretty nice.
FILIP: Yeah.
That doesn't mean that
everything will be this easy.
But yeah, if you're
using buttons,
and if you have text there,
that's going to be accessible.
And this is because of, again,
a widget that's called Semantic,
I think.
So if you're not super excited
about how accessible your app
currently is, just wrap it in--
wrap things in semantic widgets,
and that's going to be helpful.
I'm going to spend
some time trying--
you know what?
I'm just going to turn it off.
OK.
So let's get going.
So we have the app here.
So let me just quickly--
we have now two screens.
If we click here,
we have new stories.
we have top stories.
We can still open them.
We can still click this button
and get to the actual article.
And I think that's about it.
The cool thing is
it's created in block.
So the UI code is really just
like-- if I click on something,
it's going to just take
the block, take a sync,
and add a new event on the sync.
And that's it.
And then things happen
at the background.
And then over here--
wait.
Over where we're showing
the stories, we're just--
we just have our stream builder.
And we're listening
to the articles
that are coming from the block.
So it's pretty simple.
So we want to work on
the blocks a little more
so that we actually show--
so you are able to build
a circle or indicator
or some kind of indicator
that we're loading things
from the network.
Because otherwise, yes,
it's hidden in the block.
So it looks like--
here it's pretty obvious that
this is not the greatest user
experience.
Because-- see?
I don't know what's happening.
I clicked on it, and sometimes
it just takes a long time.
EMILY: There's a little lag
because it's the network in--
FILIP: Yes.
So we want to make that visible.
EMILY: So we want
to expose the stream
to do that so that people
can be like, is it loading,
and we'll just put an event
in the stream that says,
hey, loading event has started.
So the view can be anything
that wants to display
loading is happening can do so.
And then when it
knows to turn off,
there will be another
event on the stream.
FILIP: So do you want a
bool, a stream of bool?
OK.
That's--
EMILY: Yeah, I figure we
don't need anything else.
FILIP: So we need a
stream of is loading.
So a stream of bool.
And again, as always, it's
backed by a behavior subject
so that if you subscribe
to that after the fact,
it will immediately give
you the latest value.
EMILY: The most recently--
FILIP: The most recent value.
And so now we have
this is loading subject
that we need to
populate with things.
So when we first start--
get articles and update, right?
So yes, we need to
actually press this.
OK.
Update articles.
And then update
articles actually--
EMILY: Is doing the thing.
So I think what you want is--
you can say just before
you make the request,
you can set and add
a loading event,
AKA put true in the
is loading stream.
FILIP: Yes.
EMILY: And then when you're
done, you can say false.
FILIP: So I think I should put
it-- so get article-- so let's
put it here.
So is loading subject at true.
And I should add the seed
value to false, just to be--
to never return null.
And then when we're done--
OK.
So here we can do basically--
EMILY: I would do it after.
Not that it really matters,
but it's available really done.
FILIP: At false.
OK.
So nothing happens, obviously.
And now-- that was quick.
So one thing that
I'm going to do also
is I'm going to change this
to an async thing because--
wait here.
Do I need the IDs?
Oh, no.
You don't need anything.
Because what I want to do is
also wait a little bit more.
So future delayed,
something like--
just have a little bit--
because you're going to be
doing this awesome animation.
You want at least
one second off.
EMILY: But I can code
that because I can--
when we're coding
animation, I don't
have to use the stream yet.
I can just have
it always visible.
FILIP: All right.
All right.
EMILY: Don't make our data
any slower than it has to be.
FILIP: OK.
All right.
So we're down here.
I'm going to push it
to Github, and you go.
EMILY: OK.
FILIP: All right.
EMILY: So before I added
the loading indicator,
I did notice one little
bug in the code currently.
So when you go over
to New Stories,
it updates, but the
buttons don't change.
It still looks like we're
always on Top Stories, which
is kind of weird.
So the way to fix that
is in this-- basically,
we have our current index,
and it's always set to 0.
That's kind of the problem.
And so we have this--
it's a stateful widget--
so we can store
the current index.
And then when we update the
sync that we are-- sorry,
the stream that we're listening
to, we can call a set state
to be like, redraw that little--
FILIP: Which leads
to a juicy topic
of why have a block if you
have a state over here.
And I think that
as a distinction,
this is actually UI state.
To me, that's-- this is
not the state of the apps.
We could still have it
in a block somewhere,
but this is something that's
totally fine to just have
there.
EMILY: Yeah.
It's pure UI stuff,
whereas other--
in theory, we could--
the Hacker News API
is a read only API.
But if it were write only, you
could have state-- like, hey, I
marked this as read.
Or even you could
have local caching
where you could mark it as read.
But this is a pure notifying
the buttons in just the view.
It has nothing to do with
the data that we're getting.
So to do that, I'm
just going to add--
and let's start with 0.
And we'll select this.
And then it should just
a matter of calling--
and you guys have talked
about state [INAUDIBLE]
and calling set
state and all that.
FILIP: I think so.
Yeah.
If you're watching the
fifth episode of this,
I think you're an
advanced Flutterista.
OK, cool.
So we added this
little set state there.
Oh, cool.
Very cool.
All right.
EMILY: So now,
also you'll notice
there's a little bit
of an animation that
goes on there too.
The text grows
and changes color.
FILIP: That's implicit, right?
EMILY: Yeah.
We get that out of the box.
Yes.
OK.
How about we all--
so I wanted to talk
about custom animations.
But for talking about
out-of-the-box stuff first,
maybe we can subscribe to the--
FILIP: The is loading?
EMILY: The is loading stream.
I'll use the progress
indicator, and then I
can swap it out for something.
FILIP: Yes.
That is perfect.
EMILY: OK.
So just for starters, I'm
going to stick the is loading--
the progress indicator up here.
I'm sure there could be
a better spot for it,
but we're developing.
So let's just take
in the leading thing.
Progress indicator.
And progress indicator needs--
FILIP: Oh, circular
progress indicator, I think.
Because progress
indicator is an abstract--
EMILY: Is abstract, OK.
Oh, look at that.
All right.
So now this should just--
FILIP: Load forever?
EMILY: Be there forever.
Or not.
FILIP: Maybe it's there, but
it-- can you make it white?
Oh.
EMILY: I can try a
background color.
Well, that looks great.
FILIP: Yeah.
EMILY: Hmm.
OK.
FILIP: What's going on?
EMILY: What's going on here?
FILIP: Let me also look
into the doc circler.
EMILY: I swear I've
used these before.
FILIP: Yeah.
EMILY: OK.
You know what I like
to do when I get lost?
I look in the
Flutter [INAUDIBLE]..
FILIP: And you just--
just for the hell of it,
make the top bar or net
bar-- what's it called?
EMILY: That bar?
FILIP: White.
Have it a white background.
I have a suspicion
that it's there,
but we just don't see it.
EMILY: Do you want
me to change this?
FILIP: No.
EMILY: Because
they're both white.
Oh, because it's blue.
FILIP: Yeah.
And I don't know why--
EMILY: We can't [INAUDIBLE].
FILIP: The background color--
I don't know why the
background color didn't work--
of the [INAUDIBLE].
Anyway, so--
EMILY: OK.
So now we have a
forever spinning thing.
That's not very useful.
But I will-- this is
a little distracting.
Let's take this out for now.
[INAUDIBLE] like, ah!
OK.
So I'll just leave this
white for the time being.
So now what we want to
do is, from the block,
say if it's there, we will have
this [INAUDIBLE] indicator.
And if not, then we'll
have a space or a container
or something.
So now that I just
remembered that,
we can say
widget.bloc.isLoading.
And let's see.
That is-- well, we
need a stream builder.
So let's just pull this
up into another widget
because this could
get a little unwieldy.
FILIP: Yeah.
EMILY: Let's see.
FILIP: That's, by
the way, something
that we haven't done before
is create a new widget.
So that's great.
Yes.
EMILY: So I pretty--
basically, if I just feel like
it's getting nested too deeply,
it's time to pull
some pieces out.
FILIP: Yes.
EMILY: And-- so I'm
using Visual Studio code.
And this is a pretty
handy shortcut.
If you just press st, you can--
stateful or stateless.
And so in this case, we just
need a stateless widget.
So bam, it does all that.
What did I call that?
FILIP: Loading info.
EMILY: Thank you.
Too distracted
pointing out features.
So now we want a stream builder.
I'll just get--
I'm full of useful
things right now.
Stream builder.
And stream builder is going
to have our stream, which
is that is loading thing.
FILIP: Which you'll
need to provide,
I think, in the
constructor of loading info
because we don't have the--
EMILY: Thank you.
Yeah, because we got it.
So stream bool isLoading.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
You could also just provide
it with a block itself.
But this is-- yeah,
because this is--
EMILY: So yeah.
What is best block practices?
To send the whole
block, or to send
just the information that I--
FILIP: Well, for this, I
think-- yeah, you're right--
just the information.
Although if, at some point--
yeah, this one is fine.
At some point,
many of the widgets
that you will be building are
going to need more than one
of the streams.
EMILY: Yeah, for sure.
FILIP: And then it makes
more and more sense
to have a block thing.
EMILY: But just
generally speaking--
FILIP: This one-- the small one
is fine with just the stream.
EMILY: Yeah.
But generally speaking,
block pattern--
is it--
FILIP: I think most--
what I've seen is you
really pass the whole--
EMILY: The whole block.
FILIP: Yeah.
EMILY: OK.
All right.
So this._isLoading.
And it doesn't recognize
stream because I guess
we haven't imported dart sync.
FILIP: We're early
in the development.
EMILY: Imagine a
world without futures.
OK.
And then is loading.
So now we pass our builder.
And this is a bool and snapshot.
Thank you.
OK.
OK, there we go.
FILIP: [INAUDIBLE]
super helpful.
EMILY: Yes.
So now we're going to
say is it currently true.
And so-- yeah.
There's-- let's see.
If snapshot dot-- well, first
you could say it has data.
But since you've seeded
it, it always has data.
So we should be able to say--
FILIP: Yes, hopefully.
Yes.
We'll see.
EMILY: So if it is
loading, then we
want to return the circular--
nope.
Circular progress indicator.
And then else we can
just return container.
FILIP: OK.
EMILY: Yes.
That should--
FILIP: Yep, this sounds great.
EMILY: OK.
And then I will
construct, because I
don't think we're passed in.
Yeah.
Widget.bloc.isLoading.
OK.
So we just hot reloaded.
Oh, yay.
Error.
FILIP: Yeah.
That's what we
want on this show.
So what's going on?
Boolean expression
must not be null.
EMILY: So maybe it was--
FILIP: Yeah.
That's-- I think what
happens is that the icing--
so the build method,
because it's--
I think it's called before--
EMILY: Before it's constructed?
The block is constructed?
FILIP: Well, before
the next event
loop when the stream has the--
EMILY: When it's been seeded?
FILIP: Yeah.
You have to--
EMILY: Snapshot.hasData
and snapshot.data.
OK.
Let's try it.
Clear that.
And-- a ha.
Bam.
FILIP: It works.
EMILY: OK.
So now we have a very
boring [INAUDIBLE]..
FILIP: Yes, but it works.
It's awesome.
EMILY: And let us write
something interesting.
So we can have--
we can build a custom
loading animation.
And since this is Hacker
News, I know that--
well, OK, backing up.
So there's a package
called Font Awesome Icons
for all the font awesome icons.
And there is a Hacker News icon.
So we could build
something using that.
We could do a little pulsing
thing, growing in size
or spinning.
FILIP: Yeah.
Yeah, let's do that.
That's great.
EMILY: So how about--
so let's see.
I'll add-- I have to look up the
latest version of [INAUDIBLE]..
Or I guess technically--
our Pub people are going
to be unhappy with this,
but you could just do this.
FILIP: I know what
you're going to do.
EMILY: I'll look it up.
I'll do the correcting.
Good!
No.
I'll look it up.
FILIP: That's OK.
I wouldn't-- it's fine.
Just any.
So what I sometimes
do is I just put any.
There this is even more radical.
But yeah, I put any there.
And then I-- if I'm lazy,
I look in pubspec log
to see what it got to
me, and then I use that.
So that's one way to do it.
So properly, we would
go to [INAUDIBLE],,
we would find out what's
the latest version,
and put that there.
EMILY: Yeah.
Because the problem
with this is,
in theory, Font Awesome
could update its versioning
and it could do a breaking
change, although in this case
it's very unlikely.
And then our users of our app
would be like, what gives?
It doesn't work anymore.
And you're like, but I
didn't change any code.
So we have sketchily
imported fonts.
Awesome.
And pull down the package.
FILIP: Oh, wow.
EMILY: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FILIP: Is it not there?
EMILY: Let's see.
You said pubspec.lock?
FILIP: Oh, is it--
wait.
Font Awesome--
EMILY: Oh, is it
Font Awesome Flutter?
I think it is.
I think-- let's try that.
FILIP: You know what?
Maybe--
EMILY: Maybe I should
actually search.
FILIP: So Font Awesome.
EMILY: Although it is
interesting it didn't warn us.
FILIP: Yeah, that's weird.
So there is--
actually, there's two.
So one is Font Awesome, and
it's the CSS framework thing.
So you have the
CSS framework on.
And then there's
Font Awesome Flutter.
And that's the icon bag
available as Flutter icons.
EMILY: OK.
And since I've been
looking at the lock,
now I know the version number.
There we go.
Everything is above the board.
OK.
FILIP: OK.
Something is weird.
Is it just slow to update?
By the way, is this your
development box, Emily?
EMILY: No.
I do not normally
develop on a MacBook Air.
This is for compact
development while traveling.
Yeah.
I normally develop on a desktop.
So you might see the hot reload
might be a little bit longer
than normal.
FILIP: Yeah, I saw that.
That's, like, three seconds.
So I was like--
EMILY: Yes.
OK, so--
FILIP: I want to highlight that.
EMILY: Yes.
This delightful laptop is six
years old and a MacBook Air.
FILIP: Yes.
Not meant for development.
EMILY: Yeah.
I was holding out
because I didn't
know if this newfangled more
RAM thing would catch on.
So I'm waiting
for it to pan out.
OK.
So why is-- what the heck?
FILIP: It's weird
because pub get is fine.
EMILY: Yeah, it didn't complain.
When all else fails, copy paste.
So now you're happy?
FILIP: Oh, wow.
That's weird.
Maybe there was a typo.
Anyway, so that's fine.
EMILY: Meanwhile, people
on YouTube are like,
you typed it wrong.
OK.
So that's there.
That was not supposed
to be time consuming.
So let us-- let's just stick
the icon there for starters,
and we can do stuff with it.
FILIP: Oh.
So you can actually use
it with the icon widget.
I didn't know that.
That's cool.
EMILY: Yeah.
And let me show you this.
So that, and then I think
this is going to be white,
so I should change--
FILIP: Back?
EMILY: Yes.
Just get rid of that.
OK.
So now when it--
oh.
FILIP: What was that about?
EMILY: OK.
So we can't hot reload
because we added a packet.
So we need to hot restart.
So this should work if we--
no.
FILIP: Do you need to
add assets or something?
No?
EMILY: I'm just going to--
before we start,
just [INAUDIBLE]..
FILIP: Sure.
EMILY: I've--
FILIP: Oh, you-- oh, yeah.
EMILY: I'm just
like [INAUDIBLE]..
FILIP: Just looking at-- yeah.
It looks like everything.
Icon,
FontAwesomeIcons.hackerNews.
It feels like it--
it's kind of there, but--
EMILY: Yeah.
FILIP: We chose something.
EMILY: Come on.
Come on, MacBook Air.
You can do it.
FILIP: You can hear it.
EMILY: Yeah.
Oh, there we go.
There's the little Y Combinator.
So now, just for development's
sake, I'm going to get rid of--
I'm going to always
make it there
so we can see what
we're developing.
FILIP: Yes.
EMILY: So there-- does
Hacker News square, maybe?
Let's try that one.
I think it's rounded.
It's pretty.
Yeah, little rounded corners.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
Wow.
Nice.
EMILY: OK.
All right.
So to start, we can fade
in and out, do you think?
Or do you want to
do grow or rotate?
FILIP: Since it's going
to be short, hopefully,
maybe fading in and out may not
be the greatest thing to show.
EMILY: So we can set
how fast we want it to--
FILIP: That's true, yes.
EMILY: So it's always
under our control.
FILIP: Yeah.
Let's do fading out.
That's something
that seems useful.
I'm not sure if it's
useful for loading,
but definitely useful
for many other things.
EMILY: Yeah.
I'm envisioning like
kind of pulsing.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
Yeah.
That's-- yeah, that makes sense.
EMILY: Yes.
Inwardly, some designers
are watching this.
They're like, what
are you doing?
FILIP: No!
EMILY: This is why I know
[INAUDIBLE] designer.
OK.
So to do that, there is a--
I think it's called
fade transition.
And so you can just wrap this.
I'll do that.
And fade transition--
basically, it
says I'm going to fade
in and out on this thing,
or fade one direction generally.
And you say-- it takes
this intimation of opacity.
So there's a couple
of parts of animation.
Generally speaking, there's
this animation controller object
that is going to be
driving the animation.
And it will tick between values
0 and 1, like decimal values.
And so what we are
going to pass in-- so
for this animation,
this opacity thing,
we're going to pass in
this little stream that
says at this moment,
this is the value
that I should be animating.
And it will go
[MAKES TICKING NOISE]..
FILIP: Yeah.
EMILY: So I want to
add a controller.
I think we'll make
this a stateful widget.
So there's-- yeah.
Let me just type, and
then I'll explain this.
FILIP: Yeah.
So I'll try to talk
over your typing.
So what I think we
need to do is to make
this the stateful widget.
The stateful widget,
I think, needs
to mix in a class that makes
it conform to vsync, basically
making it run things or change
the animation control thing.
I'm probably not
saying the right thing.
But basically, it makes a
round of 60 frames per second.
And then with that, we--
well, we will have
our ticker, basically.
EMILY: Yeah.
So at a high level--
let's see.
Is it animation ticker?
FILIP: Try ticker,
and that should--
EMILY: TickerProviderStateMix.
So there's this--
I'm going to construct
a controller.
AnimationController controller.
This takes this
ticker provider vsync.
So vsync-- basically,
it's keeping
track of whether this
widget is in view
or not so that
Flutter doesn't spend
its energy animating things
that are not actually visible.
So by adding this
mix in, we have just
said that we are a
ticker, and so we can
increment between these frames.
And so when this
widget is visible,
then it will animate stuff.
And then we can
specify the duration.
So again, just for debugging,
let's make it really slow.
So duration, three seconds.
OK.
Oh, great.
Oh, I need to restart because--
init state.
Because init state is
only run when you restart.
That's something else.
OK.
Hold on.
Let me just clear this and--
because I have too many errors.
Oh.
I haven't hooked up--
I didn't hook up my--
this requires to have
opacity be something,
and I didn't finish
constructing it.
So opacity is--
FILIP: I think
you're one paren off.
EMILY: Oh, jeez.
Thank you.
OK.
So if we do more complicated
animations, you can--
there might be-- your
controller would direct
the overall set of
animations, and you could have
multiple animations in there.
And so you could specify--
in here, you can create
this little animation
thing that would say--
so for fading is maybe
only 1 and 1/2 seconds,
and then something
else is two seconds.
So it gets compiled together.
But since for
this, it's all one,
for now we can pass
that indirectly.
OK.
And right now, we--
I'm not even sure if that's--
so I think-- so
now we need to have
this controller do the thing.
So you can say
controller.forward.
So right now, we're
doing it always.
We're not saying
if you have data.
So we're just going forward.
So it should just
go from nothing
to fade into view over a
course of three seconds.
FILIP: Ooh, OK.
OK.
I wasn't even hoping.
Good.
That's awesome.
EMILY: OK.
So even if we wanted--
so forward produces
a ticker future.
And so when it is done--
this is the quick
and dirty thing.
We won't necessarily
do this for real.
But then you can say
then when it's done,
you can say controller.reverse.
And so then it'll fade back out.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
Let's try that.
EMILY: So OK.
Maybe I need to do a hot--
let's in and then--
FILIP: And out.
All right.
EMILY: OK.
Maybe I'll make it
a little faster.
So that's that.
But what would be cool is if--
I was thinking if
we had a couple,
and they were flashing
at different times, kind
of pulsing.
FILIP: All right.
Yeah, sure.
Go for it.
EMILY: Or we could make it grow.
Do you have a preference?
FILIP: So I wonder what's
more interesting for--
what's more used out
there in the wild.
So the two ones, that would mean
basically staggered animation.
EMILY: Yeah.
So basically, there would be--
if we want to have
it grow, it's more--
it's kind of like your
more standard widget
building things.
We would wrap this fade
transition in, say--
I think there's a--
FILIP: Scale transition.
EMILY: Yeah.
Transform-- well, the
scale, or you can--
this is a little more if
you want to do [INAUDIBLE],,
but transform.scale, and then
you can just do other things.
FILIP: Right.
Right.
EMILY: If we have multiple and
we want to have them offset,
that gets into a little
more of this thing,
controlling this
animation stream.
And so the way we could
do that is we could--
so we didn't get
into tweening at all.
Let me jump into
Animation Controller.
So animation-- where does
it talk about tweens?
FILIP: Yeah.
And by the way, that's
something that I read about once
in every three months.
And I always forget.
There's tweens.
There's animation.
There is animation controller.
And I'm forgetting about
this one other thing.
EMILY: Tween Flutter.
That will be useful.
FILIP: Yes, this is--
EMILY: No, I wanted the actual--
FILIP: Oh, the class?
EMILY: Class definition.
All right.
So this is used if you--
[INAUDIBLE] was
talking about if you
have multiple
pieces of animation
and you want one to be only
part of the full thing,
because your controller
is the full thing.
So your tween is saying I want
you to go between these two
ranges of values.
And then animate also takes
a duration or an interval
so you can say within this time.
FILIP: Right.
Right.
But I think the interval is
from 0.5, for example, to 1.0.
It's the part of
the whole animation.
It's not the duration.
EMILY: Yes, it's a fraction.
Everything is always 0 to 1, and
you have to scale in your head.
So I think the--
I think we can do either.
I think having two animations
that are playing off each other
might be a little
more challenging.
But we could do it.
We have time.
Or do you want to an easier one?
FILIP: Let's-- you know what?
So before we do that,
should we look at how
you're using the animation?
Is that how you would
start it and stop it?
EMILY: OK.
Yeah.
Let me-- yes, because
I took out the whole--
oops.
We want to say if we have data--
FILIP: So Emily is
waiting for things
to happen in the
stream builder when
there is new information
coming from our block.
So she is-- and when
there's new data,
then she runs the controller.
So she runs the
animation from 0 to 1,
and then she uses
it for the opacity.
OK.
EMILY: Yeah.
So I'm going to make
this time even shorter,
because it's now--
well, it goes by really quickly.
And there's a couple of things
you can do to show more.
So I just made it one second.
That might not even be--
you can barely see it in there.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
EMILY: So how about--
what I can do is I can
bump all the values up.
So controller is
going from 0 to 1.
What if I start at 0.5 and up?
But I have to clamp it
because it'll be mad.
It's like, your opacity didn't--
FILIP: What about-- can we do
it so that when the transition
stops--
when we say loading false,
and we say, OK, so control,
go back--
or no.
Controller, go-- to continue
with our little animation
to the bitter end, even
though we're already there.
Maybe-- I'm not sure if that's--
EMILY: So that would be--
take out this future thing.
It's possible that
if it were too fast,
we're not going to see
a whole lot either.
But what we can do is--
so if return contoller.reverse.
So this is saying start the
animation when we are loading.
And then if we get the update
event, then we fade out.
And the fade out event is the--
FILIP: But what I meant is--
so first we can guard.
So if Snapchat does not add
data, just do the container.
And then we know that
Snapchat has data.
And it's either true, which
means we are just starting
to load, or it's false.
And so if it's true, we start
the controller forward and not
do anything else.
And if it's false--
yeah.
If it's false, I thought we
would wait for the animation
to complete and then reverse.
EMILY: So that's
what I had originally
written with the then.
The thing is we are getting the
it's completed information to--
or the it's completed
event in the stream
so quickly that we
don't get to finish it.
FILIP: Right.
Right.
EMILY: So you're
saying don't process
that event in the stream
loader until we're done.
Is that what you're thinking?
FILIP: Yeah.
I think what you're
doing is basically--
if either the Snapchat has
no data, which only happens
at the start, or if it's false,
which means we stopped loading,
you immediately return
the container, which
basically removes everything.
Oh, yeah.
EMILY: So we could have this
always return that transition.
So we're always
going to have this.
This is always
going to be there.
It will-- I think
this is effectively--
it's going to look the
same because we're still--
we're going to get
that event quickly.
What I was going to say is--
this is another--
FILIP: Yeah, do it your way.
Because I just realized
we would have to--
yeah, do what you wanted
to do, because that
sounds more reasonable.
EMILY: OK.
What I was going to say is--
this is kind of a hack,
but we could say--
here.
I'm going to go back
to the container thing
because we want it to go away.
But you could say--
let's start it.
Let's try a 0.5.
FILIP: Wait, you can do that?
EMILY: So yes.
So we're going to have--
oh, wait, so this is--
now we have to do the--
we have to get--
this is returning
animation controller,
and we need the values of this.
So we want to do--
I think we need to do tweening.
FILIP: Yeah.
EMILY: So tween from 0.5 to 1.
And I think animate controller.
FILIP: Oh, yeah, that sounds--
EMILY: I think.
FILIP: Yeah.
OK.
Let's try this.
So this--
[CRASHING SOUND]
Whoa.
That's fine.
EMILY: Our whiteboard
is attacking us.
OK.
So now it's like-- it starts
a little bit stronger.
But again, it's
because we're too fast.
Again, if I take this
out, we can see the full.
FILIP: Yeah.
It's going to crash,
though, right?
Because Snapchat is-- maybe not.
EMILY: We don't use it, so--
FILIP: Oh, cool.
EMILY: And this is just dead
code, but we'll-- go away.
So this is going to
stay there in this case.
OK.
So it's--
FILIP: Oh.
EMILY: And actually, I
just realized I've been--
I've been changing
this, but I don't
think I was doing
a hot restart, so I
think it's been slower
than one second.
So I need to do the restart.
Because init state doesn't get
run when you do a hot reload.
So that's a little faster.
FILIP: Yes.
So tween is useful
when you want to do
from somewhere to somewhere
instead of the full thing.
For example, if you--
basically, you're
changing the curve.
EMILY: And you can
also-- so right now, this
is basically a linear tween.
We're just going 1.5, 1.6.
You can also--
I'm pretty sure in here,
this animate, you can say--
there's curved animations.
So you can-- rather
than march towards 1.0,
you can do these
sorts of angles.
I think there's
a page that has--
there's--
FILIP: Is in.
So these are pretty--
so if you go to
Flutter.io/tutorials/animation,
that's where you'll
find all these things.
And that's a really good read.
And as I said, I read it
once every three months.
So for example, with the
opacity-- that's something
that I just learned
recently, is that opacity,
if you go in early, it'll
look nonlinear to us humans.
Because for some reason,
we see it differently.
So they use-- the real
animators and designers
would use something
like is in or is out.
I'm not sure which one.
But yeah, so it helps
to familiarize yourself
with non-linear curves.
Because these mostly seem
like more interesting
and fun to watch for people.
EMILY: Do you
remember what the--
who defines is in, is out?
FILIP: Oh, OK.
That is curves.
EMILY: Oh, curves.
I was doing curve.
That would be why.
OK.
So now we need to--
let me just controller.reverse.
Because otherwise, it's
always going to be in there,
and that is problematic.
So we're ending at 0.5.
FILIP: Yeah, because
we're not doing anything--
oh.
You know what?
Are you waiting for the--
EMILY: Oh, I'm not.
Good call.
So .then parentheses.
They're fun.
Yes.
Oh.
This is done.
OK.
Oh, look at that.
You can see it, but it's
not [WHISPERS INAUDIBLY]..
Cool.
So what next?
Do we want to--
FILIP: No, I think we're on time
or over time, which is great.
So we-- the app
looks as it looks.
So it's still not great.
But what I'm trying
to say-- it kind of
has all the bells and whistles
that we envisioned it to have.
It needs a lot of polish,
but that will be--
I think watching that
would be even more
boring than "The
Boring Show" level is.
So what I think
is going to happen
for the next episode is we're
going to shop for other ideas
to look at.
For example, we had--
a lot of people are
asking us about things
that wouldn't really fit
into this particular-- oh,
you're making it orange.
Awesome.
To this particular app.
So we might want to start--
or even just modify an existing
app live, but not this one.
I'm probably-- just
because I'm a neat freak,
I'll probably make a last
comment to this not televised
that it's going to at
least make it functional as
of [INAUDIBLE] use readers.
Because one of the things that
we don't have still is we're
not actually asking for
the latest top stories
or the latest news stories.
So now you're only reading
five stories always.
But that's important.
I think it really looks good.
Just by the orange
thing, you made it--
EMILY: I made it--
FILIP: Way better.
EMILY: Kind of
Hacker News-themed.
FILIP: Oh, nice.
How did you get the--
EMILY: You just set the
theme, primarySwatch.
FILIP: Oh, deep orange.
OK.
Yeah.
That's great.
So yeah, that's awesome.
And then we have the
loading indicator.
We have some elements
of block in in there.
EMILY: Add some drop
shadow in between.
FILIP: Yeah.
All these things-- yeah.
For example, if you
click on the thing,
it just says story,
which is weird.
And there's a bunch
of little things
that could definitely
get better.
EMILY: That could be easy.
I think--
FILIP: Yeah, totally.
That was very easy.
EMILY: I'm going to
fix it while you talk.
FILIP: No, I was
going to end now.
EMILY: OK.
FILIP: So thanks for watching.
Please, if you have any
questions about animation,
Emily will be there
answering it for you.
There's some other stuff
that we talked about,
and we're happy to
always answer them.
But more importantly,
if you have
ideas of what app we should be
building next so that it gives
us a lot of options of things
that you care about to talk
and to implement, then please
put it in the comments.
All right.
Thank you for watching.
EMILY: Thanks so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]